in one of China's grandest locations it
staged one of its grandest shows
nearly 3 000 delegates from across the
country gathered here for China's
version of the opening of Parliament
accessing here is rare controlled as it
is closely guarded
imperfect Unison they welcomed their
leader
Xi Jinping didn't take the lectern
himself but in a way this weekend was
all about him his cabinet of allies
confirmed his third term as president
ratified
but listen closely to his outgoing
second in command just a hint that it's
not all been plain sailing
the economy maintains stability and
overcoming difficulties and the main
development tasks of the year were
basically completed in a complex
environment with many changes the
Chinese economy has shown strong
resilience
in theory they vote on legislation here
a small increase in the defense budget
this time but in practice it's all
pre-decided planned and performed to
Perfection this place is the focal point
of political power in China and although
what's happening here this weekend will
be largely ceremonial it is hugely
significant and the reverberations will
be felt around the world
but this government does face questions
not least how to rebuild an economy
battered by zero covert excesses but
there weren't many answers here friendly
questions it seemed pre-selected
experts say public trust is damaged and
does matter an unelected government that
relies on performance legitimacy
economic issue although in the party
Congress
um in last year later last year they
emphasize a lot about security but the
biggest challenge will be economic
development in China because of
community party used to rely a lot on
economic growth to boost its legitimacy
but now the problem is uh economy is not
good
there is a sense this is the start of a
new chapter of sorts for China a
post-covered era under a man who could
now be leader for Life a place with
complicated questions beneath a
carefully controlled aesthetic Helena
Smith Sky News in Beijing